here in jamaica uh i've done a lot of
education with the people here
on the time of day that they need to be
out in the sun because uh obviously it's
hotter and not as pleasant in the middle
of the day and so if they're not a
farmer or a fisherman
they have no need to be out in the sun
in the heat of the day
and so we've
done a lot of education with them saying
you know it's going to take some time
even here in the tropics for you to get
enough vitamin d
and you need to be out there
fortunately here in jamaica it's like
between 9 a.m and 3 p.m there's a pretty
big window of time that they can be out
in the sun but it's already hot at eight
so um so you're exactly right and my
paper the original one the basic review
paper
i
had a hard time getting them to assign
my final peer reviewer it was yeah the
other peer reviewers
finally approved it in the middle of
august and then i couldn't get a final
peer reviewer to be assigned and it just
languished and then as soon as i got
that final peer reviewer assigned the
very next day she approved it and it was
ready to be published i thought because
every other time i've published a paper
as soon as the peer reviewers give it a
thumbs up it goes straight to uh
production
for you know any typographical errors
and layout and that kind of thing
instead the editor
came back to me and said we have these
content changes that we need you to make
before your paper can be printed and i
was like
what
aren't the peer reviewers the ones who
are supposed to be the arbitrators of
the content of the article but no they
wanted me to remove every reference i
had
to people with melanin rich skin in
other words people who have a naturally
darker toned skin
having increased risk for vitamin d
deficiency
and that's a scientific fact
yeah and i said that would be perfectly
immoral
if i knew that this was causing a
certain group of people to be higher
risk and i refused to tell them because
i wanted to be politically correct no i
cannot do that that's a deal breaker i
will just i can
rearrange the sentences you know i can
tone it down in other ways but i can't
just omit that fact the peer reviewers
accepted it with that information i
believe that information is critical
to high-risk individuals and i won't
remove it and eventually they back down
but it was it was you know a standoff
there where
you know my husband i prayed over it and
we had made a conscious decision of you
know are we going to after all this work
allow this article to die on this hill
and we said no this is a hill i'll die
off
we have the
number of uh stories of censorship i
mean everybody's experienced censorship
on social media and twitter and now
linkedin if they've tried to share
things about vitamin d i actually have a
friend who works for facebook and i who
personally reversed some uh articles
that i was sharing that got got censored
by facebook but that's fortunate that i
know somebody there but my the second
version of
our causal influence
paper was rejected by med archive which
is a pre-print server right so
pre-prints aren't supposed to judge
content
uh they're supposed to they they have
certain safeguards which is fair enough
but the the reason for rejecting the
paper was that we used we added new use
of so quote causal language
in a causal inference study and they
refused to uh publish it and
said they wouldn't publish it unless we
changed removed that wording and
replaced it with
phrases like is associated with which is
exactly the opposite of what we were
trying to what we've proven in the study
wait wait wait wait wait so there must
be something wrong with our
zoom call because it sounded almost
exactly like you said
that there was censorship
discussing vitamin d with respect to
covid
and happening in pre-print not just it
also happens in journals with a
colleague if i you can use the word
colleague in an associate through this
community a few months ago shared
uh he had several it's a well-respected
professor of um epidemiology and vitamin
d expert and he's had three rejections
of a paper that he was
a positive paper about vitamin d
two of the replies
told him to change the finding to a
negative finding or they wouldn't
publish the paper
[Music]
but this is this is what i'm having such
a hard time conveying to anybody who is
only loosely paying attention to what's
going on with our public health response
to covet
is that
when somebody says
that discussion of the effect of vitamin
d and vitamin d deficiency
on covid is being censored on social
media platforms they've said something
utterly
remarkable
this is
a very important
factor in kovid
and i will ask you shortly to talk about
the
um
[Music]
an estimate of how much of the death
that has flowed from covid could have
been prevented if people had been aware
of the vitamin d issue and had
dealt with it but
to the extent that vitamin d
is extremely safe
extremely
cheap
and apparently extremely effective
at preventing covid when you are
widely available i mean
[Music]
stacks of it at costco you know that are
taller than i am i it's amazing what a
simple
easily accessible intervention this is
and
the fact that it differentially i mean
even your story linda about
your being told to change language about
populations having different
susceptibility to deficiencies in
vitamin d
who will be harmed by that people who
are likely to be vitamin d deficient who
won't necessarily know about it unless
someone has mentioned it so
even even this is upside down but there
is another group of people that will be
harmed by that
because the narrative was
that the reason why
dark complected people who were not
living along the equator
were
having more hospitalizations fatalities
and deaths from covet 19 was because of
health disparities
and that drove a huge influx of funds
into
public clinics and that sort of thing
that all of that funding was dependent
upon the idea that we had now proven
that health disparities were killing
people
now i
originally thought that might be the
case
until
the uk telegraph
published their wall of heroes of the
first people who had died
of covenanting the first healthcare
professionals who had died of copin 19.
the first 10 physicians to die of kevin
19 in the uk
were all
dark complected people who were
immigrants or their ancestors were
immigrants to the uk
and
just uh shortly after that wall started
being published it was up to 90 of all
the people who died in the uk who were
healthcare professionals including
uh or any any health association at all
were dark complected now you cannot tell
me that a neurosurgeon who happens to be
of indian origin
died of covid because he couldn't get
access to basic care
that is not why he died it was not a
health disparity issue right
so
this is i mean
the problem is that the simple facts of
the way information is being treated
here
if you look at it and you acknowledge
its implication it makes you sound like
a crazy person
right we have an intervention i mean
we can talk all day about repurposed
drugs and whether they do or don't work
and what the evidence says and whether
randomized controlled trials are the
answer or whether they're obscuring the
answer
but this is vitamin d
and you know i must say i've been using
it as a bellwether the very fact that we
are still not recommending vitamin d to
people in
high latitudes who are almost certainly
deficient given the evidence is an
indicator that something that to my mind
goes beyond
anything that could be explained by
incompetence is just very clear and
for you to encounter in the publication
process that some
sensitivity about interrupting some
narrative about health disparities which
as far as i'm concerned probably do
exist but even figuring out to what
extent they are explanatory requires a
discussion of what other things might be
leading to some portion of uh the
disparity and outcomes that we're seeing
so the idea that we know the conclusions
and that we are going to dress them up
as science and then provide them to the
public and in so doing by the way
prevent people from having the
information about vulnerabilities they
themselves may harbor right we're yeah i
mean my my african-american friends and
my jamaican friends and my guinea
friends are angry
that
that this censorship is occurring
because they're saying you know
they are so
yes we all admit there are health
disparities but they are so focused on
this narrative and on this end game that
they have their political agenda that
they are willing to risk the lives of me
and my friends over their agenda and
that just makes me mad that makes me
very angry and at the same time
i mean i i am just struck by the fact
that
we have
operation warp speed
to produce
vaccines
at an incredibly rapid pace an
impressive feat no matter what you think
of the product that was produced is an
impressive feat that they got there so
quickly but what have we done we have
sped
the process of
safety testing which is something that
cannot be accelerated it's not a matter
of something you can do faster because
in part what you're looking for are
delayed effects
so what we've got is a system that
pretends that it is so obsessed with
your health that it is going to cut
corners in your interest in order to get
you to something that works as rapidly
as possible
at the same time it is ignoring
something that clearly does work
that is clearly very safe and would be
the number one intervention i mean in
fact
my viewers will know that i have uh
a
i think well-founded obsession with the
concept of diminishing returns but this
is the most important thing to
understand with respect to complex
adaptive systems
which is that there are some
interventions that are highly effective
and very easy and then you exhaust those
and you move towards things which do
less and less at a greater and greater
expense and the point is vitamin d is at
the very most bargain level right the
amount of good that could be done
for the smallest amount of intervention
is probably vitamin d
and yet somehow we're up here at some
risky experiment that we're running with
some very novel technology that is
claimed to be safe but obviously there
are indications that it might not be so
safe
in terms of efficacy we know that six
months down the road it has
spectacularly
dropped off so we're dealing with some
super exotic remedy here when there's a
very basic remedy that we're pretending
doesn't exist this makes
no sense the level of financial
commitment early on
to
vaccines was so high
and for you know for the right reasons
at the beginning of the pandemic we
didn't know what we were dealing with
you know it could have been something
far worse than than than code 19. um but
once you've committed to a financial
route that's worth what trillions and
who knows how much that's worth yeah i
think just the very idea that something
as simple and cheap and widely available
as vitamin d
could be
the solution would then lead to having
wasted all of that money and all the
operational setup and i think
at some level whether it's cognitive
bias unconscious cognitive bias or
whether it's
conscious pernicious
manipulation by the people who are
making the trillions of dollars or both
it's probably all of the things that we
can think of
um
that that just led to people not not
wanting to even try because you've
mentioned pascal's wager before even if
we were wrong we knew we were one but
even if we were wrong which means he's
good for so many things
why wouldn't you just on the balance of
risks say you know we know it's safe up
to at least four thousand international
units uh actually the studies show
itself but higher than that but
thousands of
four thousand there's no one who says
that less than ten 000 is harmful that
more that 10 000 or less right it's like
why wouldn't you just do that as a
blanket recommendation to every adult uh
and then
you know see if it works yes the uh i've
started to think about it this way which
is when one
recommends an intervention one has to
think very carefully about the side
effects right and in this case the side
effects are largely positive right the
side effects will be that people will be
more resistant to other diseases
and so the point is look let's say
somehow you two have
completely misunderstood the evidence
right i've read your work i know that's
not what happened but let's say that
somehow you had misunderstood the
evidence about what was going on with
the interaction of vitamin d deficiency
and covid
then still the recommendation
recommendation would be a slam dunk with
respect to improving human health
generally with a minimal safe
intervention
if you add on top of that the incredibly
powerful evidence that this is an
incredibly important factor in the harm
that has come from covid and the point
is no rational person who was actually
interested in controlling this disease
and had looked at this evidence could
possibly have failed to make this
recommendation
well i think there's something we're not
taking into account obviously people
aren't rational uh but um
but but there's something else you're
not taking into account and that is that
most people like to perceive themselves
as being
intelligent heroes
and that's true of our public health
officials as well
and basically if they accept the vitamin
d evidence that we've provided them now
they had been duped by
previous
things and they're not heroes at all
because they should have recommended
this a year ago a year and a half ago
and so they'd be replacing their
superheroes cape with a dunce cap and no
one wants to do that well the hardest
person to
convince of something is the person who
has been
uh conned basically good so let's hope
they watch my podcast
because i i think of myself as something
of an expert at getting less dumb over
time right and the key lesson here is
that if you have been dumb
and you're confronting the question of
admitting that you've been dumb it's
still a bargain because continuing to be
dumb makes the cost go up and getting
smart as quick as possible is really no
matter how late in the process no matter
how i mean look i've told you already
when covet started i would have told you
hey you need to be a bit careful
supplementing vitamin d because it's a
fat soluble vitamin and that means
there's a hazard of overdose so we want
to figure out exactly what that level is
you know what
that was dumb that was an extrapolation
from vitamin a and it was not justified
and it presumably has had some effect on
my thoughts about whether or not it
would be a good idea to supplement
vitamin d who knows how many respiratory
viruses i have suffered from or suffered
worse than i might have because i've
been deficient in vitamin d for my whole
life but you know what
i'm not going to do that going forward
yeah you're a scientist brad and we're
scientists i mean linda and i i you know
we have many conversations
where we've both
said i'll change my mind immediately i
currently believe this but as soon as
there's new evidence i'll change my
position the three of us are scientists
that's what we do we know we're trained
to do that but i don't think politicians
unless they're scientists have that
mindset and they tend to double down
yeah but you know what you you said
something in passing a few minutes ago
which unfortunately uh fits the evidence
all too well which is that there's a
perverse incentive here for many
people there's a gigantic market that
has opened up as a result of covet and
if you imagine
sociopaths or robots running the public
health apparatus and i'm not saying that
that's what's going on but just use that
as a model for a moment and you imagine
that their purpose
was to enhance their own position in the
world
right and that these markets were
suddenly uh
spitting out cash at an incredible rate
right well then
what would they think of
repurposed drugs that work like
flavoxamine or
vitamin d which is available you know by
the pallet full at your box store
right what would they think if these
things suddenly loomed up and threatened
to control covet and
put the world back to normal yeah and as
a result of that we've actually had some
vitamin d proponents who are offering a
different message
there's a really nice
very elegant little study that was done
came out in december of 2020 but it
didn't talk about cover 19 at all
that looked at immunizations effects on
the elderly and showed that
if someone is who's elderly has very low
vitamin d and they're immunized
then when they look at their skin for
anti antibodies they find that they
don't have a strong
reaction to
the vaccination and they have a much
better reaction to the vaccination if
they have higher vitamin d levels then
they took the people who had the poor
reaction supplemented them with vitamin
d
and found that their reaction improved
and so even if you don't think vitamin d
has anything directly to do
with
kova 19
then you should at least be supporting
at this point the public health people
should at least be supporting vitamin d
as an adjunct to the immunizations
because you're more likely to get a good
response to that third or fourth or
fifth booster if you have a higher
vitamin dealer
[Music]
you